[Music]
in 2017
the supreme court legalized sports
betting it's become lucrative enough
that draftkings
one of the most popular betting sites
debuted two new
ads during the super bowl the prospect
of taxing gambling revenue
has state governments all over the
country queuing up to take full
advantage to supplement their budgets
but who will really benefit consider new
york
governor andrew cuomo ever the central
planner wants to use the state
lottery commission to license just one
gambling site
that would agree to share the most
revenue with the state
that means new york bettors won't be
able to choose from among the 10
major online sports betting services it
means the state
cares more about tax revenue than giving
bettors the best odds
and it means a state budget ever more
addicted to one more regressive
sin tax like the lottery itself it's
neither good for bettors nor a healthy
way
to balance a bloated state budget other
state governments
beware do you think state government
should tax
online sports betting let us know in our
poll
also let us know what other topics you'd
like our scholars to cover
in 60 seconds and be sure to like and
subscribe
for more research and videos from aei